20-та година суботи.
Початок зміни комісарів поліції Рaйнера Фукса та Александера Шварцера.
Вони розпочинають полювання на порушників у районі нічних клубів Кельна.
Тут багато молодих людей у надто швидких автомобілях,
які не проти поганяти центром міста.
Зазвичай це починається так.
Зустрічаються автомобілі перед світлофором,
водії дивляться один на одного і кажуть: о, ти поглянь,
глибше, вище, ширше, але в мене ще глибше, ще ширше і потужніше - і поїхали!
Через десять хвилин з'являється перший кандидат.
- За ним!
- За Ауді!
- Повільніше, повільніше, повільніше, інакше ми себе видамо.
Комісари дещо підозрюють.
- Можна чітко почути, що автівка видає дуже гучний звук.
- Тоді ми відразу його перевіримо.
Фукс - моє прізвище, поліція Кельна.
Покажіть, будь ласка, ваші права.
Водій відповідає образу можливого порушника:
це юнак у віці від 18 до 27 років. Вони люблять
тюнінгувати свої автівки.
Переважно це роблять нелегально, без дозволу.
- Що було змінено?
- Це записано ось тут.
- Що записано?
Є безліч шляхів переробити автівку: двигун, підвіска,
вихлопна система. Поліція перевіряє авто на місці.
Вона добре на цьому знається.
- 73 у вашому свідоцтві про реєстрацію, а насправді 80. Це забагато!
- Факт у тому, що були проведені маніпуляції з вихлопною системою.
Дозвіл на експлуатацію авто втрачає силу.
Характеристики автівки змінили. Хоча це і було
офіційно зареєстровано, однак експерт має ще раз усе оглянути.
До кінця вихідних автомобіль конфіскують.
У понеділок він поїде на технічну інспекцію.
Можливо,  буде штраф і попередження. Однак це
не стримує багатьох любителів поганяти.
Це своєрідне хизування. Людина вважає, що
у такий спосіб підвищує своє суспільне визнання.
Вони думають, що вони чудові водії.
Але потім, на жаль,  зазвичай виявляється, що
це не так. І саме тому вони знову і знову спричиняють серйозні аварії.
Одна з цих серйозних аварій сталася тут, на вулиці Ауенвеґ у Кельні.
Два чоловіки влаштували незаконні перегони.
Один втратив контроль і протаранив велосипедистку.
Вона померла від травм у віці 19 років.
Злочинців  засудили за вбивство через халатність.
- Виявилося, що нелегальні перегони поширилися
всім містом, і це стало надзвичайно небезпечним.
Відтоді, з 2015 року, у Кельні працюють спецзагони
проти учасників нелегальних перегонів.
Вже 11-та вечора. Година-пік для поліцейських
у кварталі нічних клубів. Уже є наступна підозра.
- Подивіться: знову тюнінгований автомобіль.
Ви бачите: модифікована вихлопна система.
Автомобіль, який відносно швидко рухається.
Спочатку здається очевидним лише одне: стійки.
Однак водій доопрацьованого авто сперечається з поліцією.
- Якщо ви не будете слідувати моїм поясненням,
ми вимушені це будемо зробити з примусом.
І згодом ми таки отримаємо ваш автомобіль, повірте мені.
- Будь ласка, ключі від автомобіля.
- Ні, ви їх не отримаєте.
- Тоді авто евакуюють.
Хто нелегально робить автомобіль потужнішим -
потенційний "гонщик" і загроза для інших. Ось чому,
за словами комісарів, вони продовжують перевірки щоночі.